but I don't think it's a it's a
productive or even a good statement to
generalize the whole nation and say oh
this is among men attraction you guys go
on Twitter because I see Hello
Zimbabwean girls some you know tweeting
this stuff a lot but it's just a small
minority that's just the loudest saying
Zimbabwe men are cheating and all that
stuff but you guys tend to go for the
Nigerian man not saying anything about
that but people also generalize them as
well but I don't believe in generalizing
anybody and I think the Zimbabwean
culture actually is good for marriages
and families all together because your
family if you had actually came back the
next day I appreciate they would have
forgiven you and they are there to keep
the family unit together